you can't place the complex numbers just
as a point on a lion so that begs the
question if this is where all the real
numbers up where are the complex numbers
now to answer this question I want you
to draw with me if you've got a rule
look there be very helpful I want you to
draw with me this tool that we use to
represent real numbers we call it fer we
just call it the number line makes it
drawn with me as pretty horrendous gonna
get the idea on the number line right
what's wonderful that the number line is
it gives us a geometric meaning for all
of the arithmetic that we've been doing
right it gives us a geometric meaning
for all the arithmetic we've been doing
ok let's think about some things and
maybe you want to jot some of these down
ok we know a numbers a point on a line
and numbers a point on the line what
does it mean geometrically I know what
the arithmetic is but what does it mean
geometrically if I add some positive
number there's a new bit of notation for
you ok you know what the are the fancy
are mean that means a real number if you
see a little plus as a superscript up
there it means a positive real number ok
so if you add a positive real numbers
any number you like suppose your number
is three right now okay and you had some
positive real number to it what
geometric effect does that have ok it
makes it to the right ok now i wanna i
want you to write this with me we have a
fancier technical name that makes more
move to the right it starts with the t
you first met up w seven
is where you take something and you move
it over we call that now transformations
is the general idea geometrically chain
something we need translate so you add a
real positive number your translate to
the right now I could say subtraction
could say subtraction but instead of
saying subtraction i'm going to say what
if you add a real number that negative
if you add a negative number what effect
is I have you're going to still
translate but to the left
okay stay with you all these familiar
operations that you've been working with
for such a very long time they all have
a geometric meaning like this we've just
covered addition and subtraction what's
the next operation multiplication ok so
again I'm going to follow this pattern
if you multiply by a real positive
number ok think about this one is to
take some thought okay again if you're
not moves three you multiply by some
real positive number like 2 ok how do
you explain geometrically what's
happening any suggestions again we've
got some language here try and use some
language that we've used in geometry
before yeah ok so if I talk about
translation I set 3 right so I'm gonna
represent three as that arrow if it's
like look there I am over there if i
multiply by a real positive number
likessee to live on of space in june ok
3 times 2 of course is seems so my new
number after having x room closet number
is over here now i know i've heard soon
I've drawn that green line above but
that's just so it doesn't overlap
however you double down I haven't
actually right I'm still on this
infinitesimally thin line it's just that
I am further along ok now how would you
describe what the difference is between
the blue shape of the green shape what's
the difference
yeah it's double the length right what
you've done is in fact translation is
just moving back and forth and your size
is preserved right but I haven't
preserved size here right in fact what
i've done is i have scaled but I'm
scaring a particular duration which way
am I going I've gone to the right okay
did I have to go to the right do I
always go to the right if I multiply by
a positive real number the answer is no
if I didn't start with three suppose I
started with say negative 2 and I
multiply it by by a positive real number
again I'm not going to go to right at my
I'm going to go to the left in other
words i'm going to scale in the same
direction whatever direction I'm already
facing right you're facing to the right
you'll go more than the right your face
until they left do go more to the left
does this make sense yeah okay follow
the pattern with me what's the next
thing have your positive at real
negative i'm going to multiply well
you've got some language now by a real
negative number okay now think think i'm
going to scale again aren't I because
it's still multiplication or what
changes
yeah I'm gonna vote that way on I'm
going to scale in the opposite direction
okay now we're almost there into the
complex world we just think one
particular thing left remember we
defined I we define I as a square root
off good so this number negative 1 is
very important to me okay when I look
over here right negative 1 is a
particular version of feet right in fact
it's a particular negative real number
that i can multiply by frame so if
you've got some number that you start
with you and then the particular
negative real number you x is negative 1
we should describe that what's happened
to the scale it stayed the same so if
you started with three you'll go to
negative three so the size is the same
but then what's happened the direction
has changed right now the direction has
changed surely other language
translation scaling what's the fancy
word I would use to say it's gone the
other way exact opposite way this is a
reflection right
that's all you need to say I mean I
can't say now i have the same size
facing the opposite direction but you
can just use the word reflect and that's
exactly what it is okay now keep this
idea in your head that multiply by
negative 1 is reflection how is that
related to this imaginary unit of
interviews well negative 1 by definition
is I squared yes now eyes not a real
number right so I can't quite fit it
into the scheme but here i squared is
just 0 times i right so whatever
multiplication by negative 1 is which
I've got over there if I do this twice
that's the same as doing this once do
you see that like that's what the equals
means after all right doing this twice x
I twice is the same as well to my my
negative 1 once make sense now what
would it mean to be half a reflection
right you that's kind of weird half a
reflection in order to get more at
better understand what's going on here
it's gonna say reflection I've got one
more translation sorry transformation
were that I have it used it back for you
seven we had translation that means
slight you've got New York scale and
then your reflection which is like
flipping what's the last transformation
you haven't
rotation right now reflection in this
context is the same as rotation by what
now normally you would say a hundred
ninety degrees when she okay but now
today we're going to say you're rotating
by pi radians which suddenly gives us a
way it gives us a a tool for expressing
this if doing negative 1 is rotating by
PI radians going all the way opposite
then what does it mean to go halfway
it's a right angle it spy on to radians
it's nice degrees okay so now I need not
just a number line like this right but
underneath this get your rule about
you're going to need more than a line
aren't you right if you draw your
familia number line and you've got this
zero and the number i was thinking i was
three okay when you multiply by I the
first time you're gonna do not pi
radians but I 02 okay so that's going to
lift you off of this real number axis
right there's like another axis like
this okay so what's going to happen is
from 3 i'm going to rotate around like
this okay when you multiply by i once
you're going to end up at 3i and any
multiple of an imaginary number isn't on
the real line that's why it's up there
okay what happens on I x I again second
time you're going to cancel that I
squared out as negative 1 yes so you're
going to come down to negative 3 over
here which is unsurprising because it's
another rotation of pie on to this make
sense so all of the arithmetic do you
know has a geometric a geometric meaning
one of the lovely things about this
diagram is it gives you an explanation
right away for what either the four is
what like before it's one why is it one
we know the arithmetic of it right I
swear I swear negative one nated 11 okay
but geometrically what it means is that
if you do one two three four quarter
turns right four terms of pie or two
then you're going to land back where you
started does that make sense yes okay so
this guy here you need to give him a
name right you might think that looks a
lot like something I've done with EE
before this is the Cartesian plane right
and does have a lot to do in common with
the Cartesian plane which is why I'll
get to that in a second but this is not
a Cartesian plane
the cartesian plane matches up a real
number with another real number we call
an X&Y right but this is not real
numbers is it right what's up here is
your imaginary numbers so instead of two
we've had an x-axis and a why antis I
talked about the real axis and imaginary
axis